[Music]
stranger things season 3 is an official
internet breaker but recently the
beloved series garnered attention for
all the wrong reasons
it turns out the new season includes a
little production error that slipped
right past most viewers
as far as spoilers are concerned we
won't be getting into anything major
here but we will be touching upon some
general story points
consider yourself warned hawkeye fans of
the show spotted a continuity error
during the fifth episode of season 3
which hit netflix on july 4th
the episode entitled chapter five the
flayed finds the gang loitering around
the local hospital where nancy is
visiting doris drisco
a woman linked to the season's big
supernatural threat
while nancy gets herself into a spot of
trouble the rest of the gang hangs out
in the waiting room
that's when 11 uses her powers to
short-circuit the hospital vending
machine to give mike and lucas lots of
snacks to share
because that's just what good friends do
trying to win back 11 after acting like
a jerk mike gives her a few m
m's as a peace offering but look closely
at that handful of chocolate candies
do you see what we see there's a red m m
this season of stranger things is set in
1985
a time when red m m's were impossible to
find people born in the era of plentiful
red m
m's probably didn't think twice about
this tiny little detail
but the fact is mars incorporated the
makers of the candy shell coated
chocolates
actually discontinued that particular
color of eminem back in the 1970s
and they didn't bring back red m m's
until 1987.
the company discontinued that particular
color because of the so-called red dye
scare of 1976
that's when the food and drug
administration published a study linking
common food additives red dye number two
and red dye number four to cancer
ruling that red dyes weren't safe for
consumption though mars used a different
red food dye to make its red m
m's the company nonetheless replaced red
m m's with orange
shortly after the fda made its ruling
the company hoped this would calm people
down and keep business booming
11 years later red m ms came back and
never left
so unless mike has his own very special
power there's absolutely no way he could
have given 11 a red eminem in 1985
unless the vending machine at hawkins
memorial hospital hadn't been restocked
in almost a decade
boy i really hope somebody got fired for
that blunder of course
anything is possible in that town
at the end of the day this goof isn't
half as bad as game of thrones infamous
coffee cup gaffe during its eighth and
final season
that incident involved a paper coffee
cup ending up on set
widely believed to be from starbucks but
actually from a local cafe in northern
ireland where the series was filmed
the now notorious cup ended up making it
into the episode's final cut and no one
involved with the show noticed
until it was too late compared to that
mistake the blip in stranger things is
small potatoes
and even though netflix and the stranger
thanks team have yet to address the
error
the official eminem's twitter account
offered up its own explanation
clearly in 1985 red m m's were around
in the upside down well played m m's
what a delicious little joke
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
stranger things are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you